[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
Christa Pike achtet auf ihr Äußeres sie
kann jederzeit hingerichtet werden sie
hat einen Großteil ihres Lebens im
Gefängnis verbracht aber wenn es darauf
ankommt steckt sie sich die dunklen
Haare hoch föhnen Sie und schminkt sich
ich bestelle immer Make-up im
gefängniskatalog sagt sie durch meine
langen Haare fühle ich mich wenigstens
noch ein bisschen weiblich der Fall
Christa Pike ist absolut bemerkenswert
erzeugt von Kranken Seelen von
durchhalte Willen und von den
Schattenseiten eines Rechtsstaates in
dem es die Todesstrafe gibt es gibt also
spannende Dinge zu erzählen schön dass
ihr dabei seid ich bin Mirko Kasimir und
ich bin Stefan hallo Christa Pike war
1996 mit 18 die jüngste Frau die jemals
in den USA zum Tode verurteilt wurde
aber sie lebt noch heute und für unseren
Fall begeben wir uns jetzt in das West
Virginia vom 10 märz
1976 hier wird Christa Gail PIKE in eine
total kaputte Familie hineingeboren muss
man sagen ihre Mutter und ihre Oma
saufen der Vater kümmert sich um genau
einfach mal nichts wegen des
mütterlichen Alkoholkonsums kommt
Christa mutmaßlich schon mit einer
Hirnschädigung zur Welt während Mutter
Teresa betrunken um die Häuser zieht
wächst Christa bei der Großmutter auf
die nicht nur ebenfalls trinkt sondern
auch einen sadistischen Lebensgefährten
hat er soll das Mädchen auch missbraucht
haben als Christa 12 ist stirbt die Oma
und Christa geht zurück zur Mutter die
hat jetzt immerhin einen Job und zwar
als Krankenschwester aber ein stabiles
Elternhaus bleibt viel Anzeige carissas
aktueller Freund zu dieser Zeit ist ein
Wüterich der sie mit dem Gürtel schlägt
trotz alledem entwickeln Mutter und
Tochter eine Bindung und kiffen
regelmäßig zusammen manchmal wenn es
Christa in diesem Haushalt zu viel wird
geht sie für ein paar Tage zu ihrem
leiblichen Vater Glen Pike aber stabil
ist auch diese Beziehung nicht kein
Wunder der Mann kennt seine Tochter ja
kaum und Christa ist eine instabile
wilde junge Frau in der Spätpubertät ein
paar Mal wirft er sie raus dann muss
trista zurück zu ihrer kiffenden
trinkenden Mutter und dem gewalttätigen
Freund jahrelang schreitet kein
Jugendamt keine andere Behörde ein in
dieses Jahr muss man sagen prekäre
kaputte Umfeld in diesen schrecklichen
Jugendjahren schmeißt sie die Highschool
und klaut sie kommt auch in
Untersuchungshaft aber später gibt
Christa sich einen Ruck und kommt in NOx
wohl Tennessee in einen
Ausbildungsprogramm für benachteiligte
Jugendliche es nennt sich jobcore die
Teilnehmer wohnen in einem Internat
Christa dürfte unter den Insassen zu den
Schönheiten gehört haben oder Stefan ja
wir haben uns ja die Unterlagen hier
ausgebreitet als pubertierendes Mädchen
fällt sie auf durch ihre tollen langen
Locken sie hat ja Porzellan weiße Haut
klare Gesichtszüge und durchaus einen
wachen und selbstbewussten Blick damals
in der ersten Zeit in der Sonderschule
lernt Christa einen jungen Mann namens
The darylship kennen und verliebt sich
in ihn
er kommt ebenfalls aus einer schwierigen
Familie und trieb sich mit Straßengangs
herum the Darrell ist ein schlanker
aufräumerikaner mit kurzen Haaren und
einer gewitzten Ausstrahlung aber die
Zeit in den Banden hat auch ihn Respekt
einflößend werden lassen
Christa will im Ausbildungsprogramm
Krankenschwester werden wie ihre Mutter
zu Daryl möchte Koch werden in dieser
Zeit gibt es auch eine beste Freundin in
Christas Leben shadolla Peterson beide
begeistern sich für Satanismus jetzt
könnte es eigentlich also bergauf gehen
zumindest jetzt was Freundschaften und
so angeht Satanismus jetzt nicht
unbedingt aber ohnehin das Gegenteil
passiert Christa hat das Gefühl dass
ihre Klassenkameraden collinslammer ein
Auge auf ihren Freund Terrell geworfen
hat Collien ist eine fröhliche frech
reinblickende Rothaarige mit breitem
Grinsen und einer Zahnspange jeden Tag
vermutet Christa das hinter ihrem Rücken
zärtliche Blicke und Persönlichkeiten
ausgetauscht werden manchmal greift sie
die vermeintliche Rivalin an lass die
Finger von meinem Freund zusammen mit
Daryl und ihrer Freundin hackt Christa
einen teuflischen Plan aus alle drei
verabreden sich mit Collien Slammer zum
versöhnungskissen in einer Nacht im
Januar verlassen alle vier den
Schlafsaal und gehen in den Wald während
Christa Collien und Daryl den Joint
drehen steht für Dollar Schmiere tja und
dann kommt es zu einer unfassbaren
Explosion von Gewalt wir können und
wollen das hier nur in groben Zügen nach
erzählen mindestens eine halbe Stunde
lang wird Collien Slammer beschimpft
geschlagen und verletzt Christa hat sich
ein Teppichmesser und ein Fleischerbeil
als Tatwaffen mitgenommen muss die Bluse
ausziehen und den BH sie fleht um ihr
Leben sie verspricht das Internat zu
verlassen und wieder zurück nach Florida
zu gehen wenn man sie nur ziehen lässt
aber Christa keine Gnade mehr sie ritzt
Collien ein Pentagramm in den Oberkörper
und am Ende erschlägt sie die junge Frau
mit einem Stein sie behält sogar ein
Schädelfragment für sich schließlich
verscharrt sie die tote zusammen mit
ihrem Freund Herr Daryl in dem
Waldgelände aber nur oberflächlich das
ist eine Art Grube mit einem Büschen
Laub drauf nach dem Blutbad zeigt sich
wie einfältig und schlicht das brutale
Trio vorgegangen ist die Tat wird binnen
Stunden aufgeklärt weil die drei damit
an der Schule prahlen und Christa sogar
noch in der gleichen Nacht damit beginnt
das Schädel Fragment des Opfers herum zu
zeigen eine Mitschülerin vor der Christa
mit dem Mord angibt ruft aber nicht die
Polizei sie sagt auch nicht der
Internatsleitung Bescheid erst als
Collins Leiche entdeckt wird
rückenbeamte an dieser traurige Fall ist
ein Kinderspiel für die Ermittler das
anwesenheitsbuch der Schule das am
Eingang vom Pförtner geführt wird zeigt
vier Schüler haben das Gelände verlassen
aber nur drei kehrten zurück bei Christa
findet man außerdem den Schädelknochen
und ein satanistisches Buch und sie
gesteht allerdings behaupten Christa
unter Daryl sie hätten Collien nur
einschüchtern wollen dann sei die Gewalt
außer Kontrolle geraten aus Versehen
sozusagen
der Prozess vor dem Gerichtshof Tennesse
sie wird von einer landesweiten
Öffentlichkeit verfolgt schließlich ist
Christa mit ihren 18 Jahren die jüngste
Frau der jemals die Todesstrafe drohte
und tatsächlich wird sie am 22 März 1996
nach nur wenigen Stunden für schuldig
gesprochen und zum Tod durch den
elektrischen Stuhl verurteilt es gibt
ein Video von dieser Urteilsverkündung
die Qualität ist kuschelig der Klang
auch das ist wie das eben oft mit so
alten VHS Kassetten ist können wir mal
rein
[Musik]
zu sehen ist nur die junge Christa von
Schreck hinten die die lockigen Haare
mädchenhaft mit einer weißen Schleife
nach oben gebunden hat sie schluchzt ihr
ganze Körper zittert während die
Richterin die Einzelheiten des
Todesurteils vorträgt Christas Freund
der Daryl der ist 17 ist bekommt
lebenslänglich und kann frühestens im
Jahr 2028 raus für Dollar die Schmiere
gestanden hatte kommt als Kronzeugen mit
einer Bewährungsstrafe von 6 Jahren
davon und jetzt ist Zeit mal über die
Todesstrafe in den USA zu reden mehrko
tja Stefan seit Jahrzehnten ja wirklich
ein sehr sehr großes Diskussionsthema
bei dem auch offensichtlich kein Ende in
Sicht ist derzeit sieht es so aus in 27
von 50 Bundesstaaten gibt es die
Todesstrafe sie war 1972 im ganzen Land
übrigens verboten worden aber diese
Entscheidung des Supreme Court des
Obersten Gerichtshofes wurde aber vier
Jahre später wieder einkassiert seitdem
wurden in den USA mehr als 1.500
Menschen hingerichtet in Tennessee blieb
die Todesstrafe vier Jahrzehnte
ausgesetzt 13 Menschen wurden seit
wieder Einführung getötet und um die 50
warten jeweils zum Teil jahrelang auf
die Vollstreckung und das führt uns
zurück zu Christa Pike denn noch mehr
als viele andere Urteile weil die
Verurteilung einer so jungen Frau
umstritten auch juristisch schon gleich
nach dem Schuldspruch legen ihre Anwälte
Berufung ein allein dies schiebt erstmal
eine Vollstreckung auf Entscheidungen
wie diese dauern mit unter Jahre auch
bei Christa 2001 verliert sie die Geduld
sie fordert die Justiz auf sie endlich
hinzurichten natürlich gegen den Rat
ihrer Anwälte am 24 August 2001 greift
sie eine Gefangene namens Patricia Jones
an und versucht sie mit einem
Schnürsenkel zu erwürgen bei der Attacke
soll die mit Insassen Natascha Kornett
beteiligt gewesen sein die kämpfenden
Frauen werden rechtzeitig getrennt aber
gegen Christa gibt es jetzt einen neuen
Prozess darin wird sie im August des
übernächsten Jahres wegen versuchten
Mordes schuldig gesprochen ihrer
angeblichen Komplizen Natascha Kornett
kann dagegen nichts Konkretes
nachgewiesen werden in der Zwischenzeit
ganz genau im Sommer 2002 geht das
Gerangel um die Exekution weiter
tatsächlich gibt es einmal sogar einen
Termin für die Vollstreckung aber die
nächste Instanz hebt ihn wieder auf
2006 fordert Christopeit durch ihre
Anwälte eine Wiederaufnahme des alten
mordverfahrens abgelehnt Christa muss
zurück in den Todestag aus diesem
Todestag gibt sie in diesem Jahr auch
ein Fernsehinterview und zwar für eine
Dokumentation
ich habe es verdient für den Rest meines
Lebens hier zu sein es wäre nicht okay
wenn ich da draußen einfach herumlaufen
würde ich weiß dass ich etwas
Schreckliches unverzeihliches getan habe
aber ich verdiene nicht den Tod für
etwas was drei Leute gemeinsam getan
haben wo ich doch nur eine
Bindung
ich weiß nicht mehr wie es ist frei zu
sein ich liebe hier länger als sonst
irgendwo vorher ich erinnere mich nicht
wie es ist ohne Handschellen
herumzulaufen oder ohne dass einem
gesagt wird wann man aufs Klo darf
Christa Pike im Fernsehen Interview
danach Vergehen wieder Jahre
2012 passiert dann etwas im Leben dieser
unglücklichen Frau gleich zwei Männer
wollen ihr nämlich zur Freiheit
verhelfen Quester hat sie per
Briefkontakt mit einem Mann namens
Donald Kohut angefreundet
er ist Personal Trainer in New Jersey
und hat sich offenbar in die schöne
dunkel gelockte Frau verliebt
mehrfach führte die ganze Strecke nach
Nashville um Christa zu besuchen
immerhin fast 1400 Kilometer pro Tour
die beiden Hecken etwas aus und darin
ist offenbar auch der Justizbeamte
Justin heffling verstrickt ihm
verspricht der verknallte Donald Kohut
5000 $ und ein Kanu wenn er die Flucht
unterstützt ich musste so ernst dieser
Fall ist bei dem Kanu auch ein bisschen
schmunzeln das ist schon eine Art der ja
ich hätte auch gerne Kanu ja aber ob ich
dafür so kriminell werde es kommt dann
auch ein bisschen wie es kommen muss
also erstmal der Plan sieht vor das
heftling dabei hilft Schlüssel für
Christa Pike zu duplizieren damit sie
sich dann quasi selbst ausschließen kann
aber Kollegen von hefflen Kriegen Wind
von dieser Sache der ganze schöne Plan
fliegt auf und zwar im März 2012 um
keine Nachahmer zu inspirieren verrät
die Justiz keinerlei Details über die
Fluchtpläne des Trios wie man hört war
das Vorhaben noch nicht besonders weit
fortgeschritten bei einem Prozess gegen
Kohut werden neben den Fluchtplänen auch
noch Vorwürfe wegen Identitätsdiebstahls
und kreditkartenbetrugs bekannt er
wandert für sieben Jahre ins Gefängnis
auch Heflin wird verurteilt nur für
christopike ändert sich im Prinzip gar
nichts sie wird wegen der Fluchtpläne
nicht mal angeklagt ihr letzter Vorstoß
der Todesstrafe zu entgehen liegt jetzt
vier Jahre zurück aber im Mai 2014
starten ihre Anwälte einen neuen Versuch
mit einer neuen Argumentation da Christa
Pike geistig behindert sei solle die
Todesstrafe in eine Haftstrafe
umgewandelt werden
Bezirksrichter Harry Mett ist Junior
fast jeden Fall auf 61 Seiten zusammen
und legt im März 2016 seine Entscheidung
vor abgelegt dagegen legen die an habe
noch einmal Einspruch ein der wiederum
abgelehnt wird am 22 August 2019
bestätigen drei Richter die endgültige
Entscheidung Christa Pike soll
hingerichtet werden einen Termin gibt es
aber bis heute nicht zwischenzeitlich
hat sich übrigens auch die Mutter der
ermordeten Collien Slammer zu Wort
gemeldet und bei der Justiz die
Vollstreckung der Todesstrafe verlangt
sie sagt ich möchte dass diese Frau
stirbt bevor ich sterbe sonst wird es
keine Gerechtigkeit geben das entspricht
dem Gerechtigkeitssinn vieler in den USA
aber ich finde auch dieser Fall zeigt
dass die Todesstrafe wirklich
abgeschafft werden muss der
Hintergedanke von Abschreckung und
Vergeltung mag zwar in Teilen
nachvollziehbar sein ist aber unwirksam
wie man eine beständig hohen Zahl an
Gewalttaten mit Todesfolge in den USA
sehen kann und in diesem speziellen Fall
verurteilt der Staat eine junge Frau die
gerade am Beginn des erwachsen werdens
steht zum Tode ein junge Frau die noch
dazu wahrscheinlich geistig behindert
ist das Urteil wird jahrelang nicht
vollstreckt selbstverständlich gibt es
keine Rechtfertigung für diese
schreckliche Tat stattdessen hätten
staatliche Stellen aber eingreifen
müssen als Christa so verwahrlost
aufwuchs finde ich auch Mirko niemand
stellt in Frage dass Christa diesen
schrecklichen Mord begangen hat aber
wenigsten ja sie selbst aber bei aller
Kritik die wir hier schon am deutschen
Justizwesen hatten der Gedanke der
Resozialisierung scheint im Fall Pike
einfach überhaupt gar keine Rolle zu
spielen hier wird einfach nur jemand
weggesperrt und zwar wie Jahrzehnte und
damit sind wir am Ende des heutigen
falls falls es in diesem Fall
Neuigkeiten geben sollte dann werden wir
die euch hier im Podcast natürlich bei
Gelegenheit mitteilen
[Musik]
wir danken euch dass ihr mit dabei wart
zum Fall Christa Pike gibt es viele
Quellen die wir hier benutzt haben unter
anderem einen Artikel aus der Bild von
2007 sowie Einträge aus den Knoxville
News und der Seite der Initiative gegen
die Todesstrafe das Skript hatte Stefan
Netzeband das bin ich die Postproduktion
gab es wie immer durch Wake world in
München Schnitt und Aufnahme Stefan
Hitze Brand bis zum nächsten mal euer
Mirko und euer Stefan